on his 18th birthday George Herbert
Walker Bush put off his impending
college education he enlisted in the
United States Navy becoming the youngest
aviator in the Navy it was six months
after the Japanese attack on Pearl
Harbor in the following years he flew
dozens of combat missions all across the
Pacific Ocean after one such mission in
1944 his plane planes engine was set
ablaze by enemy fire forcing him to bail
out over the ocean after being rescued
several hours later by a u.s. submarine
Bush reportedly wondered quote why had I
been spared and what did God have in
store for me as it turns out God had a
lot in store for George Herbert Walker
Bush he became successful in the oil
business in Odessa Texas a u.s.
congressman the 10th ambassador to the
United Nations the chairman of the
Republican National Committee and also
ambassador to China the director of the
CIA served eight years as Ronald
Reagan's loyal vice president which was
one of the most successful presidencies
in history and of course he was elected
the 41st president of the United States
George HW Bush had one of the most
notable resumes in the history of the US
but his personal life was even more
impressive
along with his beloved wife Barbara of
70 plus years he was a parent to six
children including former president a
former governor he was a grandfather to
seventeen and a great-grandfather to
eight
through it all he never forgot the brave
men who and women in this country that
protect us every single day make
everything possible including in 2004
when he sat down for an interview with
yours truly take a look you know you
know it touches me Shauna
I'm admit living in some what of a
cocoon as a former president but I go
out of my way to say hi to these
policemen and the firemen there and I'll
tell you the ones that I talked to were
for your son
pretty word for the one I lift up the
back of his lapel like that at a big
George that'd be a but it's totally they
watch fox news every night well I mean
to them guys but but you know the this
is this these people are not elitist
Country Club people they're saving our
lives with their service heroes and when
they say we're for the president I'll
tell you I get very emotional Devin well
the more this interview coming up in its
entirety in just a few minutes but
obviously in both his personal and
professional life President Bush was
always a good decent honorable person
serving his country during his four
years in the Oval Office eight years as
vice president he had to deal with some
of the most challenging issues in modern
American history he saw the collapse of
the Soviet Union after a successful
strategy with President Reagan called
peace through strength he ushered in the
reunification of Germany he constructed
literally and conducted the first Gulf
War in response to Saddam Hussein's
hostile actions an attempted takeover of
Kuwait and along with his predecessor
Ronald Reagan George HW Bush transformed
the country at that time creating 21
million new jobs it was at the time the
longest period of peacetime economic
growth in American history they took the
country get this double-digit
unemployment double-digit interest rates
inflation to amazing lows the very same
thing by the way if President Trump is
now doing after the disaster of the
Obama economy they inherited the economy
of Jimmy Carter but of course the Bush
presidency did not go without some
controversy
they all have controversy some
criticized him for not taking out Saddam
Hussein after he decimated the Iraqi
army in Kuwait in a very short period of
time he's also attacked on the issue of
his no new tax pledge you might remember
was the infamous read my lips no new
taxes since Ronald Reagan Bush
encountered a media that was actively
rooting against him and it's only gotten
worse since then take a look can you
explain how you were supposed to be the
you are you an anti-terrorist expert we
Iran was officially a terrorist state
you
I wanted those me out of their world
president also got a chance to see a
supermarket checkout scanner in action
and it seemed as though we never really
seen one of those before and the
president said that he was amazed the
Bush campaign has really been a model
and how you elect somebody who who even
his friends think was a weak national
candidate we find it's very steady work
keeping up with Bush's lies they do keep
coming very thick and fast lying is
something that comes to him alarmingly
easily it's something that he resorts to
with I think it's a slightly worrying
sort of skill what you saw there was
only the tip of the iceberg during his
reelection bid the New York Times
reported that fake story about President
Bush's so-called amazement at super
market scanning technology they tried to
paint him as out of touch although
widely refuted the New York Times
included this fake story in its obituary
of the president meanwhile the so-called
journalists at the AP they couldn't hide
their contempt but now the former
president even passing away tweeting
quote George HW Bush a patrician New
Englander his presidency soared with the
coalition victory over Iraq and Kuwait
but then plummeted in the throes of a
weak economy that led voters to turn him
out of office after a single term has
died he was 94 a tweet has since been
deleted but of course this is all part
of a pattern isn't it the mainstream
media viciously attacking any prominent
Republicans all while providing cover to
all of their friends in the Democratic
Party Reagan was portrayed as a
heartless monster the eight years he was
president George Bush literally bashed
for his speaking style among other
things John McCain excoriated throughout
the 2008 campaign as racist and worse
Mitt Romney called the sexist and
misogynist because he wanted to hire
women apparently these attacks are just
obviously completely disingenuous when
you have the people die and all of a
sudden they now like them like we saw it
Senator McCain most in the mainstream
media oh they'll do a 180 after they
excoriated and when I was running for
president and treated him horribly
seemingly forgetting about their nasty
coverage a pattern to destroy people's
names of character when they're alive
and then create a veneer of
bipartisanship and
then we'll say nice things about
somebody when the person dies it's so
transparently phony we've got the video
evidence take a look hi there I'm
Stephanie ruhle clearly a little broken
up breaking that pledge showed the
character and resolve of the man to do
which he was persuaded was the right
thing to do economically even though he
knew at the time that it might guarantee
that he'd be a one-term president we are
warning something greater than one man
in some ways we are mourning an ideal
because President George HW Bush was the
last of the greatest generation such
respect for the position the institution
of the presidency what our what a
special person what a patriot what a
person of service to this country
and of just incredible decency and an
example to Oh
let's praise former President Bush who
the media was never nice to maybe you
can use that to bludgeon Trump now when
the dust of partisanship settles history
will look back on 41 as an American hero
and when his country called George HW
Bush he answered that call he answered
the call in the Pacific at the ripe age
of 18 like so many in his generation
including my own father he answered the
halls of our nation's bureaucracy as he
entered that he answered the call as the
41st president of this country he did it
as a father as a husband and now answers
once again to his beloved Barbara Bush
in heaven after they both had an amazing
73 year marriage thoughts and prayers
tonight go out to the entire Bush family
and over the years I did have the
opportunity to sit down with President
Bush we're gonna play that interview
coming up before we get to that
interview I first turned to a lot of
breaking news we start in France tonight
where tensions are very high after very
violent protests against the French
president Emmanuel macron are taking
place this all started as a
demonstration by Frances yellow vest
movement against the country's crippling
gas tax designed to quote fight climate
change now this comes as gas prices in
Paris are now already over $7 a gallon
really insane and so far across France
those
tests have left three dead hundreds
wounded over 400 have been arrested as
it turns out I guess socialism high
taxes and government enforced climate
change didn't exactly lead to societal
euphoria instead of pushing a massive
climate change agenda it only puts a
bigger burden on who the lower the
working-class people of France and
anywhere else they use this and while no
one supports violence and destruction
should we be surprised this should serve
as an important warning to everyone here
in the US
we'll continue to monitor the latest
also new developments tonight as it
relates to the Muller witch-hunt
breaking today according to a report
from Michael Isikoff remember him Robert
Muller is now tying off loose ends and a
probe that appears he says to be coming
to a close this comes today as author
and 72 year-old jerome corsi filed a
criminal complaint against the special
counsel alleging that Muller and his
team of democratic lawyers sought his
false testimony and by the way laying
out how quote dr. Corsi has been
criminally threatened and coerced to
tell a lie and call it the truth and mr.
Corsi explained on this show he rejected
a plea deal because he refused to lie
because under oath and before God pretty
courageous decision given that is 72 and
literally threatened with what could be
a life sentence in jail for not agreeing
to test the lie to the special counsel
this is the opposite of how our justice
system supposed to work in America we
all were brought up to believe that was
supposed to investigate crimes and then
find perpetrators not the other way
around
remember there's still zero evidence to
date of any Trump Russia collusion
nothing remember general Flynn George
papadopolis pled guilty to process
crimes as a result of the investigation
itself nothing to deal with the
investigation man affort guilty on some
counts pled guilty to crimes Oh on loan
applications and tax issues going back
to 2007 taking place way before you ever
joined the Trump campaign and instead of
investigating the obvious collusion at
Obama's DOJ and commis FBI and of course
them using dirty phony campaign op
research that Hillary paid for from
Russia
well they continue to push only the
phony partisan Russia
narrative only to bludgeon undermine and
D legitimize these duly elected
president we now have also in that vein
breaking tonight Comey has reached the
deal with House Republicans to sit for a
private deposition after trying to force
a public hearing now will he ever be
held accountable like Michael Cohen for
lying under oath remember he said the
report about the Clinton investigation
wasn't written before she was
interviewed that was a lie
apparently we don't have equal
application of our laws one standard for
Republicans another for Democrats like
Comey and certainly maybe even a third
system for the Clintons entirely and by
the way thankfully tonight it might be
closing time for the Clintons shady and
once lucrative business of turning
political access into hard cold cash
according to long longtime New York
Times columnist even Maureen Dowd while
a recent joint speech by Bill and
Hillary Clinton was pretty disappointing
at best she writes quote they're
pathological need to be relevant in
America's bolide by a Canadian arena
where stretches of empty seats bear
witness to the passing of their
relevance even the few showing up they
were getting a discount according to a
new report tickets to see Bill and
Hillary slow as 11 bucks in some of the
locations if you asked me that's still
overpriced okay a lot more to get to
tonight latest on the caravan the
media's latest low as it relates to the
passing of President 41 George Herbert
Walker Bush and you won't believe you
will not believe how one teacher decided
to ruin Christmas for five and
six-year-olds but tonight we first
remember the legacy of service President
George HW Bush we're gonna go back to
2004 I had the opportunity to sit down
with the former president ahead of that
year's presidential election
let's take a look it's gotta be harder
to watch your son the president than to
be president it is far worse when they
go after your son and I would say
unfairly a lot of the time then when
they used it when I was in the cross
crosshairs and we get condemned and
criticized somebody even when I thought
it was unfair about me
it hurts much more when it's your own
son
yeah and humanity with a close call not
even close because I think about my son
who's a lot younger than yours but I
would think that's got to be a lot
harder and you may
to go through this one more time you
know I just thought that other son he
was in Florida he's good he's good and
they singled him out for two years ago
as the number one target for the
Democratic Party nationally not just for
governor
they were Senate have Terry McAuliffe
for whom I don't well put it this way
not very high on him we came and made
this the number one number one goal for
the Democratic Party nationally and Jeb
won by 14 points did they were and the
polls were a little closer going into
that election that's right and he won by
much wider margin and I guess made it
didn't mr. McAuliffe a little unhappy
about that you know your son said
something the other day that really
struck me he really did want to go to
Washington and change the tone something
that he was able to accomplish in Texas
yeah since he's been there and I'm not
talking about the michael moore's or the
pundits on TV yeah we'll get to him in a
minute
oh well good Harry yeah but but former
Vice President Al Gore screaming George
Bush betrayed his country Ted Kennedy
regularly calls the president a liar he
concocted a war for political gain have
you heard the leaders of the Democratic
Party that shrill I've heard him shrill
and I've heard some of our shrill in the
past but I've never felt the climate
like it is now nor the shrillness of the
political opposition it hurts
well yeah you expect some of it but when
when it's your son and they call him a
liar when they when they impune his
motives it hurts a lot yeah you think I
feel strongly about it talk to Barbara
Bush shake her she just gets tells me
not to watch and all of that but I can't
I can't not watch you're engaged I read
recently that she won't read the New
York Times anymore and she done tells
you to stop whining about it when you do
read it yeah well I still read about it
in that morning more and much more
publicly than I used to think because I
think they've gone too far I think
they're advocates for the Democrats I
think they have lost their
objectivity that they did have many
years ago I think there's a certain
arrogance amongst a lot of their people
I think you know you expect this on the
op-ed page you got people in there
that's mere George and slam him every
day but that's you know that's different
but when the news columns when you see
subjectivity creeping into the news
columns it concerns me yeah I think
they'll deny it's happening and I said
well too bad I think it is there you saw
back in the but at the convention the
protesters Michael Moore conspiracy
theories about the Bush family you even
commented publicly about about him well
he's bad and I know I didn't go to see
his movie and so he'll say well how can
you criticize me when you didn't say hey
we've had tons of people go to see it
it's just my problem I don't want to pay
one dime that some of which might
eventually end up in his pocket but he
is a below-the-belt guy he knows that
because my family are public persons we
couldn't can't don't have any access to
making him tell the truth he made some
comment I understand in this doc
documentary that's getting him all kinds
of liberal Fame that we got a billion
two hundred million dollars out of the
Saudis or we were enriched by that but
he has it very cleverly gets it in a way
that there's no no libel I don't like
him and I don't know him and I don't
want to meet him and I don't like his
movie and I'm not gonna see it how's
that for fairness like to fill it not my
talkshow yeah no at that's offering
strong opinions Zell Miller when he
spoke at the Republican convention had
some incredibly harsh criticism of the
Democratic Party and he said where yes
where is the bipartisanship when we need
it most
he's talked about a manic obsession to
bring down your son our commander in
chief he said they're motivated more by
partisan politics by national security
today's democratic leaders see America
as an occupier not a liberator do you
see a shift in a change I mean we we had
in years gone by FDR and JFK and Truman
and the modern Democratic Party well I'd
refer to
Zell Miller about the shift and change
because he he was one and now he's not
and he he he's watched he's worked with
him his own party and he you know as
Reagan said the party left him and
that's what Reagan said about the
Democrats you were involved in a
revolution when when when President
Reagan and when you were vice president
and you proposed your economic plan and
you were going to cut taxes a lot of
people predicted a depression would
ensue
yeah he had the longest period of
peacetime economic growth 20-plus
million new jobs were created when you
decided to build up our military and and
what President Reagan called a gap of
vulnerability and confront the evil
empire there were those that predicted
World War three would ensue
but we know what happened the wall came
tumbling down right so there was a lot
of criticism that is it similar I mean
if you look at the district I think
there's some similarity from the critics
some of the same critics Ted Kennedy
friend your friend Ted kept my friend
Ted we have a very pleasant personal
relationship but you know I when he goes
after the president in a personal way I
don't like it wonder man he knows that
you know you know it touches me Shauna
I'm admit living in some what of a
cocoon as a former president but I go
out of my way to say hi to these
policemen in the fire arm in there and
I'll tell you the ones that I talked to
we're for your son are great word for
the one I looked up the back of his
lapel like that at a big George that'd
be a but it's the same guys it's totally
they watch fox news every night guys but
but you know the these this is this
these people are not elitist Country
Club people you're saving our lives with
their service heroes and when they say
we're for the president I'll tell you I
get very emotional at that you say about
the Bush family
it's not about legacy it's about duty
and it's about honor and it's about
service that's is that something you and
the president talked about that no but I
don't need to talk to him about it
because I know what motivates him I know
it's motivate him over his over his
lifetime
and I'm just saying at this stage of my
life what that matters service duty
honor country service to others helping
others points of light and family and in
my case with our two public figures sons
it's a pretty easy fit and you're proud
of them and you said you think you'll
win substantially I do
I honestly believe it but you know I
could be wrong I thought I'd win and
that only Mary Madeline now how do you
keep the country but I got you know look
at it this way the Lord works in
mysterious ways Sean and if I have one I
doubt that the president would have been
president today maybe in the future and
Jeb might not be serving admirably in
his second term as governor service duty
honor God family an amazing man amazing
family